Paris Jackson and Macaulay Culkin get  matching tattoos  [Music]  the 36 year old actor and the 19 year  old model were spotted getting inked at  tattoo mania in West Hollywood on  Saturday Paras showed off their new tats  on social media sharing this pic of the  pair's arms and what looks to be  matching spoons though the two didn't  elaborate on the meaning behind the ink  Michael Jackson's daughter also posted a  snap smiling for the camera  the fresh body art on full display what  Paris and Macaulay often spend time  together she's the former child stars  goddaughter and was friends with her  late father  [Music]  Paris's outing with McCully comes just  one month after the eighth anniversary  of her father Michael Jackson's death  [Music]